adam non je vous le rappelle on a appris
ce soir le décès de l'écrivaine marie
claire blais à l'âge de 82 ans elle
laisse derrière elle un riche héritage
de plus d'une cinquantaine de livres des
pièces de théâtre des recueils de poèmes
pour en parler ce soir un de ses
admirateurs notre collègue l'animateur
michel désautels mont saint michel sur
celui michel faisait-il un des seuls à
qui elle accordait des entrevues alors
quels souvenirs vous gardez de cette
grande hauteur
eh bien d'abord beaucoup de chaleur et
ce soir beaucoup de tristesse ou si je
suis probablement comme ses lecteurs les
plus fidèles y en a qui l'ont suivie
depuis des décennies depuis les années
mais j'ai eu la chance vous disiez de la
rencontre et d'interviews à quelques
reprises et c'est c'est très difficile
parce que quand on ait eu la chance de
dire de percer
le mystère marie claire en entrevues en
personne vous savez elle avait les
photos les plus anciens comme les plus
récentes nous montre la même chose avec
art absolument magnifique mais qui était
toujours caché par cette frange un peu
derrière lequel se réfugient et c'était
un symptôme une manifestation physique
de son comportement envers les autres au
départ et une fois qu'on avait réussi à
briser à faire relever cette mèche de
cheveux on découvre une femme qui est
extrêmement chaleureuse qui aimait le
monde des mairies ou si derrière ça peut
paraître étonnant mais c'est une femme
très drôle et surtout qu'ils aimaient
l'humanité et ça je ne serai trop
inviter les gens qui ont été peut-être
un peu réticents à aller vers sa
littérature qui est pas facile d'accès
c'est pas toujours 5 on l'a reconnu par
tous il ya donné les honneurs qu'il
mérite très largement mais c'est pas
toujours une oeuvre facile et surtout le
dernier cycle par exemple soif qui est à
mon sens 95 qui s'est terminée avec une
rencontre près de la mer 12 13 ans plus
tard ce sont dix romans mais ce sont des
fleuves de mots dans lesquels on sait là
je le répète plus pour les autres qui ne
serait pas il n'y a pas de point il ya
un gamin quelques uns très tellement à
le reste ce sont des dons elle nous en a
nous oblige à à nous impliquer comme
lecteur est surtout entré dans cette
manne que là c'est une femme qui a
toujours milité pour la défense des
minorités en tous genres qu'elle soit
sexuelle
raciale économique c'est une année à
l'italie si
oui où et de ce ça c'est certain et à
l'étranger comme en france aux états
unis on reconnaît que c'est une que l'on
décrivait francophone elle a été
traduite ou s'il est en plusieurs
langues mais c'est surtout ça une grande
militante finalement alors ce sont des
romans deux frères mans mais qui montre
à quel point l'amérique est malade à
quel point l'amérique n'aime pas ses
enfants à quel point c'est dur d'être
une femme d'être une
lesbienne une transexuelle d'une tranche
jean d'être noir d'être métis dans ce
pays d'à et du début jusqu'à la fin de
cette oeuvre absolument immense il ya
malgré tout un peu de lumière que ça
parce qu'il ya toujours il ya de
l'espoir et croit que chez les gens dans
le fond chacun d'eux est assez de force
et lumière pour se sortir des conditions
et puis misérables alors c'est un
normand s'est achevée immense pas facile
mais tellement avait bien beau cadeau si
on a la patience et dans ses lectures et
de la compagnie il ya vraiment la
lumière au bout du tunnel
je crois en 2018 comment est-ce qu'elle
percevait la suite de sa carrière à ce
moment là la suite des choses pour elle
aubin il continuait d'écrire elle était
assez content d'avoir fini le cycle ne
m'avait dit à l'époque oui mais j'en ai
pas tout à fait fini et effectivement
elle a depuis repris avait commencé à
reprendre certains des personnages en
les isolant davantage nom final le nom
de tribus qui constituait dans ce set
ils imaginèrent quelque part qui est en
fait qu ouest soit la grande île l'écu
plus tôt mais donc elle avait repris ses
personnages les uns après les autres
c'était l'ambition suivante je ne sais
pas où elle en était junior des
circonstances dans lesquelles elle est
décédée mais
on ad'un soif des clés pour découvrir
l'amérique qu'elle voyait qu'il a
désespéré mais qui nous invite à espérer
et malgré les critiques elle a essuyé
parce qu'elle en a essuyé certaines
certains l'accusent de redondance un peu
denses et les vous l'avez toujours
soutenu c'est à dire que j'ai j'ai j'ai
eu la patience de d'aller dans ses
livres et elle reconnaissait savait fort
bien que beaucoup de gens là bandana
jours de route certaines n'osent même
pas ouvrir des premières pages devant ce
flou de moules a quand même moi j'ai lu
cette patience cette humilité aussi
devant quelque chose que je comprenais
pas toujours au départ mais une fois
qu'on a compris les quelques clés et la
construction qui est immense et une ya
plus de 200 personnages dans soif par
exemple qu'on retrouve d'un livre à
l'autre et qui évolue dans le temps donc
c'est si vous voulez découvrir ce qui
est certaine une certaine amérique
d'aujourd'hui c'est une formidable façon
de faire chez une femme qui était au
moins aussi américaine que québécoise on
sent tard elle est divisée depuis
tellement longtemps donc c'est c'est une
façon de le faire et moi j'avais eu la
patience parfois le courage de toujours
mais quelle joie ouais là et elle a eu
de nombreux prix le magazine new yorker
la place parmi les écrivains de fiction
vivants les plus notoires et les plus
originaux donc le fait qu'elle ne
mettait pas de points c'est une de ces
raisons là j'imagine oui c'est ça mais
elle était extrêmement apprécié connue
aux états unis à la limite beaucoup plus
qu'ici dans le circuit universitaire
américain qui très importante aux
écrivains elle était accueillie partout
en star mais pas ce minimum par
maintenant depuis des décennies elle
était connue de tous qui compte en
littérature donc on doit être très
triste dans plusieurs milieux ce soir
d'apprendre que marie-claire la secrète
marie-claire toujours caché dans son
pied ouest avec quelques amis tout
proche et qui détestait pas aller
prendre son verre au coucher de soleil
sur un des quais du bout de la
presqu'île
une belle image je suis une belle image
en terminant merci beaucoup d'avoir
partager vos souvenirs avec nous